well hey Mark how you doing good Steve
how are you Mark how you doing I'm great
hey Mark how you doing I'm doing fine
Mark how you doing hey Mark how you
doing hey Mark how you doing hey Mark
how you doing hey Mark how you doing hey
Mark how you doing hey Mark how you
doing hey Mark how you doing hey Mark
how you doing hey Mark how you doing hey
Mark how you doing hey Mark how you
doing hey Mark you're doing that was my
life for about 15 12 40 years or so
really if you don't know what that is
man that's obsessive compulsive disorder
now I'm not talking about you know I'm
gonna get dressed while I'm talking I'm
not talking about you know
you got to go back and check and make
sure that the stove is turned off or the
door I'm talking about like being stuck
under your bed you know for four hours
saying something over and over again
while horrific images are going your
head and you have to counter each one of
those things that goes in your head with
something positive
so
anyway OCD kicked in for you at what
what age I was you know the first OCD
attack that I actually had
I was five years old and I met somebody
there was somebody that their house had
caught on fire okay and we were talking
about it my parents my mom and my
brothers and sister and uh it scared me
and before I went to bed I kept saying
to my mother as her house because I was
worried about it and then before I went
to sleep I I it's over and over again I
said our houses in kitchen for houses
and kitchen for our houses and catch on
fire houses and kitchen over and over
again then I just fell asleep and then I
just kind of that kind of faded out and
I forgot about it and then the OCD came
back when I was probably around the
fourth grade I think it was
and it started out
with uh I mean I went to take a glass of
water off the table to touch it and when
I touched the glass for some reason I
could not pick it up and drink at it had
something to do with like odd and even
numbers like the first time was an odd
number which would make you odd
something of that sort so anyway I uh
I touched the glass again before I could
drink it and then uh and then after that
it would it's like increased I'd be
doing that all the time whenever we sat
down for dinner and Steve would always
have to touch the glass one time before
picking it up and pretty soon my
brother's like what the hell are you
doing and then from there it increased
to where I would be touching it multiple
times before I did so anyway uh
yeah
and from there it just got it just got
it increased it wasn't it and then I
developed over a period of time the
system where
like certain numbers I remember a while
like odd numbers were always no good and
then like the number 13
was always like the bad luck number so I
always had to avoid 13 or anything
related to 13 like three and so then it
became like another example like if I
say I've picked up this shoe okay see I
picked it up see what would happen then
is like negative thoughts would come in
okay and uh I would have to counter
those and it could be anything I would
have to counter those with a positive
thought it could it could be any number
of things uh it could be something like
uh
I don't know uh you're not gonna you're
not gonna uh pass this you know the
seventh grade or something could go in
your head so say say I went to pick up
my shoe okay and it went uh
you're not gonna pass the seventh grade
okay then I'm about to pick it up again
and say myself I will pass the second
grade okay now what happens is you've
got
that I picked it up the first time okay
so then I counted it with the second but
that's no good because the first time is
still stronger because it was the first
time you did it so you'd have to do the
third time
I'll pass seventh grade okay now you're
at two to one too good to one bad which
is okay but you still got the number
three in there now which is like 13 so
you gotta get rid of that so
I'll go to I'll pass and go to the
seventh grade just say it a third time
okay now you got three good to one bad
which is four which is okay but you
still got the three in there so that's
not good so you got to do it again
I'm gonna be passing you know go to the
seventh grade okay so now you've done it
four times to one which is good and in
the earlier stages I can walk away at
that it would be okay you'd be done with
it but what started happening was by the
time I got to the fourth one that bad uh
thought would come back in it wasn't
even really like a thought it wasn't
even really like a thought it was like
uh it's almost like you're saying it
yourself like I hear myself say like I'm
saying it and I'm kind of like like
countering that with no that's not I'm
gonna graduate I'm gonna go to the
seventh grade you know or whatever and
but what would happen is that that bad
thought would come in again so then you
have to start the whole process all over
again okay and it always stayed in the
in the category of you could never it
always was like the counting was always
one two one two which would be four then
one two one two which would be four more
which is eight then you'd start to get
one two one two which is four again and
so on and four more is eight and then we
got the 16 you would stop and you'd
start it over again one two one two you
never counted like one two three four
five six seven and it was never like
that it was always in you know keeping
with one two one two one two four to
eight sixteen then you start over always
always avoiding the number 13. sounds
exhausting oh yeah and this sound and
that sounds like messed up but that's
like nothing to what it actually ended
up turning into and I always thought
that you know this is something stupid
ridiculous I'll stop doing this in a
couple years I'll start and I know and
it didn't stop it kept getting uh
it kept getting worse well anyway I went
through like like I had a and it started
to affect my life more like I would miss
out on things like you would like if you
got out of bed in the morning the first
thing when your foot touched the floor
you had to have the right thought okay
if you did you'd have to get back in bed
touch the floor again and and start over
and again it was always in that same
sequence it was never just once it was
always in that same sequence of one two
one two before you had you had to avoid
the number three and stay in that zone
and there was different things like
there were times where like there was a
thing for a while where I was always
like spitting because I felt like there
was something like a contaminant or
something in my mouth I'd like keep
spitting it out I would walk and I have
to touch the floor again you know all
those kind of things I had a paper route
which I was very good at too you're
basically self-employed with a paper out
you buy your papers every sum I made
really good ones are very good business
man I was just like young kid I was in
the sixth grade and but then in toward
the end of my route I started to have
the thing where I would have to I would
put the paper in someone's door and then
I'd go do two more house then I have to
go all the way back to the other door
knowing that I put the paper in there
and still check so so a paper app that
used to take me maybe 45 minutes an hour
would take like two hours okay and so it
started affecting me you know more and
more like that
and again at this point it wasn't like
it wasn't like you know the end of the
world wasn't devastating it was always
something I thought well you know I'm
gonna I'll be able to beat this thing
I'm gonna you know a couple years I'll
look back at this and laugh at I always
thought that and one of them uh I mean
was it it was annoying at times you know
it was a real you know a problem okay
but it didn't start to really get bad
until like I started going into it like
toward my high school year so I started
getting down that's when now I had a
kind of like a remission like in the
eighth grade where it went down and my
grades went straight up I was like
getting A's now you know what I mean it
was like I had all these plans like I
was planning on I grew up in
Pennsylvania I was planning on going to
Penn State you know I was either going
to probably major in law probably get
into politics you know I had it all had
it all figured out but then once I hit
hit high school he got bad and it got
ugly and it got really bad
uh oh also if you haven't noticed uh I'm
a professional clown you know uh how
fitting is that though you know you
always figure like the clown what's
behind that painted smile yeah it's
really a crazy person uh anyway uh I had
this one incident happen with an OCD
attack uh this was going toward like I
was going into the ninth graders in the
summer
and uh
there was this friend of mine and a
friend of theirs was like I had a cop
that was a friend they had this like
police camp thing okay and we were uh
you know he asked if I wanted to do it
so yeah man I'll go what do I care when
we went to take this physical right now
and this is this is a part of me okay I
grew okay where I grew up I grew up at
like I grew up in a small town Erie
Pennsylvania uh but I was in a we were
the we were like would be the rich kids
in that area it was a private
neighborhood you know a pool tennis
court all that kind of stuff so we were
we were wealthy kids in that small
community not wealthy like you'd see in
LA but wealthy uh but anyway we went to
this physical thing and all the kids
there were like you could tell most
these kids were like dirt poor and I
hate to admit it but the way we were
brought up you know we were to consider
that we were better than these people
you know it was horrible you know I look
at that now and I developed this fear
that if I went to this Camp I would be
like these kids you know what I mean and
so I didn't want to go at all and at
this time my parents were getting
divorced my mother was seeing this
[ __ ] who I hated this very day and
she married and he was over and I didn't
want to go my mother's like insisting
that I go and I developed I was I was
literally terrified
that if I went to this thing I would end
up like these kids I mean I really
believe that it was like horrible so
anyway I had this major attack and I'm
like it was like it was an OCD thing
then but not quite like with the rituals
yet but it was definitely an OCD thing
okay but anyway that was like it was
like it turned out to be a big like I
don't know I was yelling and screaming
and crying it was like freaking
ridiculous you know what I mean anyway
anyway I went to the thing and then once
confronted with the people I still had
like the OCD attacks and I'd have to say
over and over again it might not be
successful I'll be successful I'll be
successful I'll be successful I was
that's kind of I had to keep saying that
but once I got there and confronted it
you know I was I was okay but anyway
that was like the start of it really
getting bad but the first time that I
had no CD attack that I was really
scared I mean actually scared me was I
just got back from the beach and my
friends and I were riding home on our
bikes
and uh
football was really big where I came
from this town in Pennsylvania and
Pennsylvania was really big in football
back in those days you know without
equipping it was really like you know
and I went to one of the best football
schools in the state you know we were
like ranked second in the state my
junior year we were like one of the best
schools in the state a small school
though and so football was huge at my
school it was like the big thing so it
was very important to me you know to
start on the football team and I played
in eighth grade I started at a pretty
good so I had a really good season and I
was like an up-and-comer
and anyway we're riding our bikes back
and uh my friend was in front of me and
uh all of a sudden the thought went in
my head you're not going to start on the
football team and it like I was like I'm
gonna start a football team I'm gonna
start a football team I'm gonna start a
football team and I'm saying this I'm
going to start but then the bad one kept
coming at me not gonna start I'm gonna
start on the football team I'm gonna
start off with him because and he just
can't and I couldn't catch up I couldn't
say it enough times to catch up to the
negative one and then it scared the [ __ ]
out of me so it's like your negative
thoughts are fighting against you yeah
and it kept as every time I said I'm
going to start the other one would slide
in affirmations and then and I couldn't
catch up to other times it would happen
but I could catch up to it pretty quick
this time I didn't and then finally when
I caught up to it and I was like oh [ __ ]
I was like dude I was like you better
stop this you better knock this off
because this is getting out of control
now you better just stop doing this okay
and uh and from there it just started
getting out of control now I did have a
bit of a like during the season I had a
bit of a remission I guess it wasn't so
bad and I had a good season too I
started and I kicked ass man I was like
an up and coming you know star on the
football team you know the head coach
knew me I was I wasn't going to be one
of the big big guys you know and uh and
wrestling season came around and OCD
really messes up wrestling because
wrestling's like 90 in your head won't
just step on the mat and if you're
heading together you know you're gonna
have some problems
all right so anyway the OCD attack
started getting worse and worse okay and
now
some really scary [ __ ] started coming in
my head that didn't it didn't happen
before thoughts of like doing harm to
other people started entering the
entering the picture like you know
killing your family or something that
would really really terrified me and I
had to counter those with like say a
thought when my head you know you're
going to kill your sister I would have
to say I'll say mister's life I'll say
mister's life I'll say mr's life okay
and and those started coming more and
more and they were starting to really
like get bad like I was starting to
really and you and I never in my it's
crazy because you know you're not going
to kill your sister yo but for some
reason it's like the fear is so strong
it's like you have to say that if I'm
not taking it it's like I'm not gonna
take any chances I got to keep saying
this [ __ ] until I get it caught up is it
because you love your sister so much
that no no it could be anybody actually
that's part that's part of it but it
could be my sister my brother it could
be a guy on the street anybody this
could come in you know it did no it
really didn't have anything to do with
it uh I mean maybe a little but not
really it could just be anybody uh and
you would have to you'd have to counter
it
all right so you have those thoughts
okay and you would have to counter them
by saying the positive thought and if
you didn't then you would go and like
kill this person or something now you
know that that's ridiculous you know and
you and you're constantly in a battle
with yourself saying this is stupid it's
true you know that you know it makes no
sense you know that why am I saying this
okay and then you're like and then you
think am I crazy and then you think
you're crazy that's even worse because
oh my God what if I'm crazy you know and
you know it makes no sense it's
ridiculous and stupid saying this is not
going to change a thing okay but the
fear is so strong you have to keep
saying it now I've been told from books
I've read that basically when you have
OCD basically like say you go to pick
something up okay your serotonin moves
this way you pick it up after you've
picked it up completed the serotonin
moves back that way task completed
you're done with OCD serotonin doesn't
move back it stays there so you're
compelled to do it over and over again
now that I I I've read up on that now as
far as the horrific thoughts that are
coming in there with that I don't know I
don't know where those come from but
anyway
uh
I still have really bad attacks and one
of the worst attacks I ever had
was okay this was during this was in
1977. I don't know if you're familiar
with this there's the blizzard of 77
like like Buffalo was like uh you know
it was like for like I don't know like a
week and a half or something like snowed
constantly you know they had to bring
the National Guard into Buffalo we were
in your ears like between Buffalo and
Cleveland and then I think Pittsburgh
south of there but we got hit with the
snow too we're out of school for like a
month now massive snowstorms and uh
there's this one morning
okay I got up out of bed somehow I made
it and I was getting the point where I
was hard to get out of bed because I'm
doing that thing where I got the right
thought again and I was standing by I
went and looked out the window you know
the snow and it's everywhere
and and the thought goes in my head I'm
gonna go downstairs and murder my family
okay
and it scares so right away you know I'm
Gonna Save my family's life and then it
comes back up and save my family's life
I'm saying my family's life and I kept
saying trying to get but these bad
thought just kept coming in and coming
in and the more that it comes at you the
more stressful it is and the more
stressful it is the more the OCD kicks
in even more before long I'm terrified
man I'm like next thing I'm stuck by
that window I've actually I wrote a book
about this and that's one of the
chapters is uh stuck by the window on a
snow day and before long I'm like
terrified I'm gonna I'm gonna murder
everybody I'm gonna go now I think I
actually my sister and I were only ones
there but I think I'm going to murder
her or whatever and and I'm like I'm
like I'm like I'm saying it over I'm I'm
Gonna Save My I'm Gonna Save my feelings
I'm gonna see my feelings I'm gonna say
my feelings but it just kept commenting
and I couldn't catch up I was terrified
man before long I was [ __ ] crying
tears are pouring dummy because I was
terrified and my sister comes down the
hall and sees me and she's like and she
knew I was having things were [ __ ] up
then people were noticing now and she
was just like it's like Steve you got to
get some help man just walk away you got
to do something she'd know what to do
anyway
I finally got it under control and it
was weird like when you had a bad attack
like that it was like if somebody in
your family died or something somebody
you close to you died that's how you
felt after you it was that strong after
you finally got it under control
but anyway went downstairs and I'm still
pretty [ __ ] up and she's like Steve
just go downstairs just lift weights do
something keep your mind up and nobody
knew what was wrong with that was
another it was [ __ ] up because back
then nobody knew what OCD was like
somebody gets OCD now they know nobody
knew what OCD was then it wasn't until
like the 80s that they [ __ ] and you
thought you're the only person in the
whole world that did this [ __ ] nobody
else you did it it was all you so you're
like [ __ ] on your own man there was
no help whatsoever so anyway the attacks
kept getting worse and worse I had an
attack once during a wrestling match
when I was sitting after before I
wrestled I was like doing something like
with my hand and people stuff like
really embarrassing which was bad but
the time I was so [ __ ] up I really
didn't think about it but anyway so
after a while my parents kind of were
like okay they thought they weren't
doing because they're busy fighting over
their [ __ ] divorce and what these
[ __ ] crazy people there with you know
they were this like and the thing was
you know the only thing that keeps me
saying I think today is when I was a
little kid like little I had a great
childhood I mean had everything man good
loving parents the pool the house the
you know I mean it was like the American
dream and that's the only thing it keeps
me sane today
all right now like I said it was getting
really bad at this point
and
my cousin John was overstanding he was
going to school in Gannon then he's a
really cool guy and uh and the whole
house was falling apart now everything's
a wreck it's my sister me with my dad my
brothers went with my mother and my
stepfather and we got this crazy [ __ ]
in our house and anyway uh there's a
show on television called violence in
America and when I was younger I loved
that show I used to love 60 minutes I
was like really into like education when
I was a kid I was like a brilliant
debater even as a little kid I used to
like do these debates in school and bury
people in the show violence in America
comes on has shown me like these serial
killers and they're talking about
horrific things they're doing and
obviously with OCD now I'm freaked out
okay it's really bothering my dad
noticed it was bothering me doing while
I was watching it and he was saying
maybe you should just go upstairs but I
but then I had to keep watching it
because the next part was going to be
about like little league kids playing
Little League football in the inner city
and the violence there but like for some
weird reason that was okay okay so I had
to watch that the offset like you know
Charles Manson in these sick [ __ ] you
know what I mean it's like violence in
football was okay you know you could do
that that was it was just that's how OCD
is it makes no goddamn sense it makes no
sense whatsoever okay anyway uh
so I'm watching the show
and it's free you know it's like really
getting to me and I'm obviously I'm
having OCD attacks well anyway I finally
go up to bed and I'm laying in bed and
of course you're going to be you're
gonna be a murderer gonna be just like
those guys you know I kept saying
something like a lot of people how do
you say saying over and over again and
then
like images started showing like like I
literally saw like Charles Manson right
in front of me looking at me you know
like look and I'm like [ __ ] terrified
then I'm gonna have to think of like
sports characters You Know Jack Lambert
or you know Joe green or whatever to
offset the image of this guy over and
over while I'm saying this now my cousin
John finally came up and like he yelled
at me like be quiet because he was
trying to sleep and then I had to say it
to myself real quiet over and over and
over again and all I didn't sleep all
night said rituals all [ __ ] night
[ __ ] up I'm terrified I'm gonna be a
mass murderer whatever so I go to school
the next day I don't know Algebra test
at that time I think I had to be in
algebra because math was usually pretty
easy for me and I could Ace this test
this was a turning point in my life this
was this was when it this was the point
where it all fell apart I mean I'm
taking the test and I'm so [ __ ] up
with the OCD and the rituals and
everything I couldn't even take the test
I got a nap I failed it and after that
all my grades
all F's failed like everything because
after that that's when OCD took over now
one of the one of the worst things
is that it really affected me by was
okay first of all you couldn't pay
attention in class because while I'm
sitting in class and the teacher's
giving a lecture I'm saying rituals over
and over again in my head you know I'm
into this I'm you know again it could be
for anything there's literally it could
be a fear of being gay fear of uh being
unsuccessful fear of you know not
starting the football team fear of uh it
could be any number of things you have
to say it over and over and over again
so I'm not able to pay attention to
what's going on in class anyway reading
I couldn't [ __ ] read for [ __ ] to this
day I can't read now let me explain this
to you when I say that I can't read okay
a paraplegic knows how to walk but he
can't walk it's the same thing okay when
I would go to read a book okay so I'm
reading the book you know the man walked
through the store and saw a dead dog
like when I saw the word dead obviously
I would have to say live live live live
live live live over and over again to
catch it up or else somebody would die
close to me okay not only that I would
have to go back in that book and find
the word live the offset where I read
saw dead and if I didn't find it I'd
have to go do another book okay and find
the words live okay okay now obviously
so I couldn't [ __ ] read not only that
okay
with the and that can happen all through
when you're reading any any word could
trigger an attack okay and what happened
was
because of that over and over again that
happening like most people you just pick
something up you just read you don't
think twice about it you just look you I
can't do that when I go to read my brain
automatically to this day stops
okay you gotta have the right thought
before you start reading got to see the
right color blah blah blah blah
everything has to be just right before
you can start reading so automatically
my brain stops okay from me from reading
so even to this day I can't read but let
me put it this way I can read in the
sense that sometimes I've read many
books and you may say that doesn't make
any sense okay I can like let me give
you an example here you could have me
write down a paragraph and then ask me
to read that same paragraph that I just
wrote I wouldn't be able to read it
you'd be like what do you mean you can't
read it you wrote the thing how can you
not read it when you just wrote it and I
wouldn't because my brain puts a stop
now in saying that I've read hundreds of
history books and things and then when I
say that I've read those if I pick up a
book on my casual on my own
I can start I'll start I can read it
I'll be able to read the book now I may
get I will get stuck from time to time
while I'm reading stop have some OCD
attack then continue so I can't read in
that sense but when I say I can't read
like if somebody just hands me something
if you hand me something right now and
say oh could you read this it's like it
stops me that's that's kind of what I'm
saying and you would think and I read
Christ I don't know hundreds of books
trying to beat this and you would think
that the more you read that that would
change it's opposite of that because if
I haven't read anything in a long time
it's easier to pick something up and
start reading when you read all a lot
then it just increases it's I again it's
it's OCD and it's uh it's it's crazy
[ __ ] [ __ ] anyway Now by this
point my parents are like okay
something's [ __ ] up with this guy
we're gonna do some help now my mother
okay
I show up at her house one day for
dinner and then all of a sudden now and
the first one now I'm terrified of going
to a psychiatrist because the neck's
going to confirm that I'm crazy I'd seen
the movie One Flew Over Cuckoo's Nest
and I'm thinking if people find out what
I'm really doing I'm gonna get a [ __ ]
lobotomy or something so you don't want
anybody to know the truth that you're
[ __ ] nuts and I'm telling myself I'm
not crazy that's probably that was one
of the attacks too I'm not crazy I've
said that too I don't know I'm sure I
did but anyway so she says oh we're
going I'm like going what where and she
was going to take me to some psychology
I was like again I'm freaking out I'm
crying I'm like
I tried if I would have got in touch
with my dad he would have said [ __ ] them
man I'll go run get away I'll come pick
you up because my dad was like you know
we were tight he would he would have
[ __ ] came you know [ __ ] them anyway
my sister was coming to ease the thing
he really needed to go but she had some
issues too but I'm not going to get into
that uh hers were caused by [ __ ]
other people but anyway uh to go to the
shrink and I my sister when I talk about
turnout she said she remembers me tell
him about it I don't remember telling
this guy anything about it really so
anyway that just didn't work at all I
never went back then I'm still [ __ ] up
so my dad then now it's his turn to send
me to a psychiatrist okay so but my dad
he's up front about it you know he's not
playing games he's like no you're going
at this time no no [ __ ] no surprises
no [ __ ] nothing and that's the way it
is I don't well too [ __ ] bad you
don't want to go you're [ __ ] going
you know and which is better okay and of
course I was pissed off and mad about it
but I'm not it was like a like a thing
that was just thrown at me then now I
will say this for my mother it wasn't
her she did have it in her heart to help
me okay so I can't you know what I mean
she Moon about it the wrong way but she
it was in her heart she wanted to help
me but anyway so now this is really
[ __ ] up all right now remember nobody
knew [ __ ] about OCD back then it wasn't
like today it's like going to this like
now here we go my whole life has been
[ __ ] destroyed here I was is really I
was oh yeah it was really good looking
too you may not believe it now when I
was younger that's one thing I did I was
like [ __ ] I was really handsome and I
was extremely popular okay and uh
anyway so I go I had everything in the
world going for me man I was like of
course I could have been a senator today
you know I mean it's like and then this
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] where I gotta
say things over and over again is
destroying my whole [ __ ] life
everything's being destroyed it's
affecting me in sports it's figuring me
and my education expecting me by social
and disrespect it's [ __ ] me up and in
every aspect of my life okay and and I
go to and because I got to keep because
every time I think of something
something a bad thought I gotta say a
good thought to counter it this is
what's [ __ ] just destroying my life
so I talked to this what is this [ __ ]
shrink say to me he says to me you know
see everybody thought it was like I'm
upset about the divorce or some [ __ ]
I [ __ ] give a [ __ ] about the divorce
well maybe I did I don't know but anyway
uh this guy the psychiatrist says to me
you know we could do Steve is we can
teach you how to think of a good thought
when you have a bad thought and I'm like
what the [ __ ] I'm like in tears I'm like
that's the [ __ ] problem and you're
telling me to [ __ ] what are you [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] I'm here I'm here because
of this and this is what the guy did I'm
like at that point I knew you know it's
over I was like okay you know what man
you're on your own dude nobody's gonna
help you nobody can help you nobody's
ever gonna get this you're just [ __ ]
there's nothing you can do so I decide
okay what am I gonna do I'm gonna beat
this thing one way or the other and I
always said that all through this thing
I always would determined one day I'm
gonna overcome this [ __ ] I I you
know I stayed at him and I said I'm
gonna beat this thing on my own my way
but in that meantime I'm gonna hide this
nobody is going to know about this I'm
going to cover it up and go and I did
and I did it ingeniously now one of the
ways I did that was like say I had to
pick something up like this now I could
if I physically picked it up over and
over again people could see that so this
ingenious plan was you touch it now I
could slowly slightly like leave my arm
like this and slowly put pressure on it
and that would count as picking it up as
a touch and I could do that and people
wouldn't notice okay maybe they noticed
a little but not like picking it up over
and over again those were little
ingenious ways I came up with hiding it
another thing I'd explain why what you
know why is he getting all that so why
is he failing his classes
they're going to question that what do I
do how do I counter that ah what do I do
I decide that I'm going to be one of
those guys that doesn't give a [ __ ]
about school you know I don't care I
just want to party drink or the parties
you know play sports I don't care about
school I don't care at all about grades
and so I played that image I played that
part and I played that part perfect and
people bought into it they believed it
okay and it worked I was [ __ ] popular
as hell I was just like the party guy
you know that was completely not me I
wasn't like that at all I loved school I
loved the [ __ ] I loved education I
wanted nothing more than to be educated
but but I'd rather do that than let
people know that I was [ __ ] crazy
okay and anyway so I did it and it
worked I remember one time like it
worked because I remember my dad he
thought I was okay that all this [ __ ]
had gone away and one day I just said
[ __ ] it and I had an attack and I didn't
try to hide it he says why are you doing
this again you were better you were
doing all right and I just looked at him
I was just like you just don't know you
have no idea you don't know because he
didn't know he didn't know I was hiding
it so anyway
I go through High School and again but
somehow by some miracle I did graduate
but anyway I'm going to get back into
one of the darkest and I really was like
questioning whether I should talk about
this
because it's very disturbing and uh it's
very difficult for me to talk about it
uh but but I figure if I'm gonna be
honest in this video I'm going to bring
it up you know what I mean it is this is
very difficult I had to really think are
you really going to bring this up but
I'm going to bring it up because I have
to bring it up because it's it's very
important okay
all right so meanwhile my stepmother
moves in with us right she was my
stepmother at the time they weren't
married yet and meanwhile her sister
moves in too and my sister her sister's
like [ __ ] with my sister all the time
which is bad that was a that's a whole
nother thing my poor sister went through
now my stepmother this is one sick
[ __ ] [ __ ] she would all right let me
start with this
I think the first Christmas she was
around okay like she bought me this 48
inch black light which was really nice
gift I was like wow that's cool and it
was like weird because
it was I might wear in the living room
too we used to always open presents in
the family room when we were a family
but now it was some weird thing I don't
know but anyway we're in the living room
and after she gave it to me I can
remember who said they somebody they
were saying oh give her a kiss give her
a kiss I'm like it's [ __ ] weird we
never did that [ __ ] [ __ ] it was weird
and so my mind and I go to kiss her like
and she kisses me on the lips and it
didn't feel right it wasn't like when
your grandmother gives you a kiss there
was something different about this
something kind of weird that I really
didn't know what it was but this wasn't
the [ __ ] regular kiss something just
something felt weird about this okay it
just wasn't normal well anyway as time
went by
this [ __ ]
no my I'm 14 my sister's 15. she starts
telling us
explicitly sexual things she's doing
with my father I mean she's telling
these kids telling us this stuff she I
mean graphic details she's talking about
putting like Hershey's chocolate syrup
on my dad's [ __ ] and licking it off
she's telling a 14 and 15 year old kids
this [ __ ] meanwhile they're banging all
the time we hear him at first we're like
you know our kids were listening then
after a while it was like we're like we
couldn't even sleep and like shut up
she'd leave the door open so you could
peek in and see her getting banged this
[ __ ] was [ __ ] up man okay so she's
doing all that [ __ ] and a meanwhile
she's always touching me she's always
like putting her own hands on me and
touching my arms and my legs oh yeah
it's just like it's like you know this
is like you know something's [ __ ] up
it's a sexual thing happening here man
that's what she's doing and I don't get
it I don't see what she's doing I don't
see how she's pulling me into this [ __ ]
right because I'm a [ __ ] young kid
man I'm in the middle of [ __ ] pubert
I'm 14.
so meanwhile
let me do you know I'm just gonna save
and do them because I got it okay so in
any way like what I think if she picked
me up from football practice she would
say oh lay your head down on my lap and
she's like have shorts on my head would
be on her lap you know and then right
before we got got to that oh no get up
get up get up now get up now because she
didn't want anybody to see because she
knew what the [ __ ] she was doing was
[ __ ] wrong okay and it just kept
going further and further that she'd
bend over so I could like see her
breasts you know she would expose
herself and it was like little by lips
got more and more it was a sexual thing
I mean not I'm a [ __ ] kidding people
my dick's getting hard by this and at
the same time I'm like I don't want to
do this I want nothing to do this my
father's [ __ ] wife for Christ I don't
want anything to do with this [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay but first I could not stop it
I did not see what the [ __ ] she was
doing to me and then one day and it's
going it's getting out of control now
and then there's one day my little
brothers were over because my dad out on
the weekends or something or it was
maybe during the week a couple weeks of
the summer and they were my dad was
downstairs making spaghetti my brother
said you could hear him and I walked
past their room and she was laying on
the bed and for somebody reason I walked
in the room I laid down on the bed next
to her next thing I know we're like
kissing passionately and I'm like
sucking on her tits and it's like and
I'm saying to myself while this is
hypnosity this is wrong with me this is
wrong this is going too far man you got
to stop so I stop it okay and I was
sitting on the edge of the bed and I'm
like [ __ ] up man and she comes over
and she and she looks and she looks at
me in the eyes and I was [ __ ]
terrified man I was [ __ ] terrified I
was like [ __ ] I was I was literally
Frozen I was like paralyzed I knew she
was going to do something [ __ ] up that
I did not want her to do and I could not
stop it I was [ __ ] paralyzed because
I was just like terrified and all of a
sudden she pulled down my shorts and
started sucking my dick next thing I
knew I saw [ __ ] stars I'd orgasmed
and and there was no pleasure in it
whatsoever nothing it was nothing it was
just a horrible [ __ ] experience and I
just sat there Frozen in [ __ ] fear
immediately after it's over immediately
after I came the OCD home came pounding
in at me of course and she gets up and I
hear her walk in the bathroom spit up my
[ __ ] common rinse out of her mouth
and I'm I'm I'm still sitting there
Frozen like I'm [ __ ] Frozen man I'm
in fear I'm terrified I can't move I'm
still paralyzed she's like she says
something to me like I like please my
man and then you better get dressed you
know and I so I pick up pull up my
shorts and I go in the bathroom and
immediately man I'm I'm washing my dick
over and over and over and over and over
because I'm contaminated my whole body's
contaminated I gotta get that was
another thing I had to get into it's a
contamination thing with those either be
washing my hands constantly until they
bled now that was that's a whole thing
so now I'm completely contaminated right
I got to get this contamination off me
that she's not put on me okay I'm
completely content I'm feeling so guilty
how could I have done this to my father
oh my God this man loves me only person
how could I have done this to him oh my
God what kind of a horrible person am I
how can I I'm so guilty I went
downstairs then I heard they called me
down for dinner I couldn't even look my
father in the eyes from that day on
things with my father he'd never been
the same after that never again was it
the same and I I couldn't I I was did
you ever find out uh well just this
comes late later
and so
I'm uh I'm just I couldn't even look it
was terrible so then we were all going
to the pool like our pool was you got
everybody had a key to the pool Club I
should go at night if you want so we all
went to the pool and I couldn't go in
the pool because if I jumped in the pool
because I was contaminated then the pool
would become contaminated as well as
well as all my clothing were not
contaminated they would all have to be
thrown out okay the big problem was I
had my wrestling socks on and if you
started on the team you get vars it
looks like a big deal now but if you
were a starter you could keep your socks
it was like if you had four sets of size
you're a four year start it was a big
deal you know and uh is I didn't want to
get rid of those so I got rid of
everything else I was had a problem my
underwear I had on was like your
standard white briefs I didn't throw
those out because I didn't throw
everything out right away eventually I
did but then I didn't know which pair of
underwear I'd been wearing at that time
so now all my underwear became
contaminated now when you have
contaminated clothing that means there's
certain things you can and can't do
while you're wearing that clothes I was
just I was [ __ ] I was [ __ ] in every
way okay so anyway we're at the pool and
I go in there's a shower at the pool so
I go in the show and I'm in the shower
I'm like okay just take a shower get all
the contaminants washing and washing and
washing watching we couldn't get and my
stepmother comes running around
eventually it's like get out of there
somebody's going to find out when what
we did so so I had to get out of there
and then of course I jumped in the pool
I had you know the pool's contamin I
could never go in the pool again [ __ ]
that's that's over for me now but anyway
so now at this point in my life the
major OCD attacks were coming from my
stepmother okay I'd have to counter
everything and it's and it's [ __ ]
weird because
you want me to continue on my makeup
okay uh I'm gonna try to talk while I'm
doing the makeup on this okay and the
thing that's like [ __ ] weird about it
is I was horrified by it it was terrible
by the OCD attacks
but yet at the same time
my dick was getting hard I was like
sexually attractive I'm [ __ ] a 14
year old kid you know I mean you can't
you know I mean you're [ __ ] you're
just I was [ __ ] you know that's why
you don't do that [ __ ] the [ __ ] kids
you don't [ __ ] with their heads like
that you know it's so anyway
for a minute there I actually kind of
went and pursued her and she did push it
away for a minute I think she realized
hey I shouldn't have [ __ ] done that
and then and then at that point I know
then after that I didn't want to go
anywhere near I want to touch him
because for one thing it was the OCD
that was like the main best thing I want
you know and anytime she like bumped up
against me or I would have to wash it
like if my arm actually rubbed against
her I'd have to like wash wash it off
and wash and wash it all constantly and
then there was all the nightmares I had
tons of nightmares and I'm [ __ ] her
my father oh it just completely [ __ ]
my head up sexually just [ __ ] me up so
bad now and then I got another problem
here I'm thinking okay and this actually
came later in life uh well I would say
to myself okay
then this was like like later after I
was out of high school and that and
where the [ __ ] still bothered me and I
would say to myself okay now
if I hadn't had OCD okay and because of
the OCD attacks I didn't start banging
her if I had If I Didn't Have OCD would
I just kept [ __ ] her and what does
that say about me that see yeah it puts
me in a [ __ ] [ __ ] up situation
either way I couldn't [ __ ] win man it
was [ __ ] [ __ ] man I like that slice
that bitch's throat man anyway
all the OCD attacks became trigonite now
I had another problem first time I had
an orgasm right it's from [ __ ] her so
the only way I have to I have to get rid
of that now okay that means I gotta have
another girl suck my [ __ ] dick and I
have to come from that to offset what my
stepmother did or I'm [ __ ] man I have
to have that so I started seeing this
girl in school who had a reputation for
like you know banging around or like you
know
just she was one of those girls were
easy right and I was very popular like I
said I was like I was like Steve Trio I
was the big man man [ __ ] I was
gorgeous every [ __ ] game you could
have any [ __ ] girl I wanted I was the
kind of guy where I know this is very
arrogant but it's true I was the kind of
guy where women would just walk up to
you and give you their [ __ ] number
you know I mean I was that [ __ ] one
of those guys you know what I mean and
uh then my hair fell out I was [ __ ]
but but anyway uh
so I had to find so anyway so so I go
out with this girl right
and I'm a shut up she invited me to come
to her house for a party she was like a
nerdy girl like she was in the band and
[ __ ] and she was like you know she was
really kind of a nobody you know what I
mean but she was like kind of cute she
wasn't like ugly or anything uh so
anyway I go to her house for a party my
friend of mine showed up at the party
which I was surprised well he was dating
some girl in the band so his name is he
was I should have said his name huh I
shouldn't put people's names in there
yeah but anyway uh
he uh he was a cool guy he was on the
wrestling team we were pretty good
friends and uh he's like yeah man you
take her back to my car I got my car
back there so I took her back to the car
I'm thinking all right fine I can get
this chick to suck my dick I'll come and
I can I can get you know I can really
get rid of that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
offset that she said sucking my dick
nothing it's like I felt nothing it was
like there's no feeling at all
because that [ __ ] [ __ ] up my head man
I could to this day I can't come from
getting ahead from a woman it never
happened I can't do it because what she
[ __ ] did to me it can and not now I'm
like [ __ ] now I'm like now what the [ __ ]
am I gonna do I'm [ __ ] I can't even
[ __ ] [ __ ] come from some other
girl and you [ __ ] giving me head and
I'm stuck with that so now and I had to
I had to have this happen or else I'm
going to be trapped forever because my
stepmother [ __ ] did this to me and
don't forget I'm the one that was
responsible I did she did no wrong it
was me it was all me I always thought it
was all me that's what these [ __ ]
pieces of [ __ ] do they do this to
[ __ ] you know and the [ __ ] thing
is you know
not I'm wanting to go there but
anyway so now what do I do so now I'm
thinking okay well
I'm gonna have to bang this girl man if
that's sex if I have to have sex with
her okay and come from that that's even
stronger than just getting ahead so
that'll offset it I can do that all
right so
so anyway and and the thing was to have
sex with her again don't forget I got
OCD before I can since this is the very
first time like anytime you're doing
something for the first time everything
had to be right you had to have the
right time you could never have like 13
after or something like that or 47 which
is 13. everything had to be exactly
right before you did something the first
time so if it was gonna be the first
time I had sex with I'd have the right
clothes on that right thoughts all right
you had that exact right positive
thought the minute you came everything
had to be perfect okay so it's like
almost an impossible situation so the
first time we had sex I don't even think
I even came because I was having OCD
attacks the whole time and then
eventually I did I don't even remember I
couldn't remember like the actual well
my first actual like sexual encounter
now it has to be this [ __ ] my
stepmother which I can't even enjoy
which is [ __ ] like sickens me when I
I can still I can still smell that
[ __ ] [ __ ] I can still like the scent
of her it's I can still smell it in my
head and it's disgusting me man I just
want to like [ __ ] punch in her
[ __ ] face
anyways I know I'm getting a little you
know people who know Music Cloud I'm
like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna hire this [ __ ]
guy you know but but it's an important
that I talk about this because this was
a major OCD thing that I went through
okay so once this [ __ ] [ __ ] realized
this is not how you behave as a clown no
obviously not no no I'm not at all
you're a successful crime I'm a very
successful clown I'm amazing with kids
and never no no no this is this is me
tell this is me for the first time
coming out and telling the truth about
you know how I ended up a clown head
essentially because I had no other
option well that wouldn't go that I'll
get back to all that anyway so now what
happens is
now my father like I said was a good guy
but he could be physically abusive and
he had been abusive to me before
when I was younger that's like this time
we went camping or something he just
like my brother he was told us to be
quiet my brother said he freaked out he
pulls me out of the [ __ ] bunk and
starts beating the hell out of me with a
[ __ ] belt and I got welts all over me
and [ __ ] you know and which was [ __ ]
up he he would be and he would never
touched any of my other only me I was
the only one but anyway so now this
[ __ ] okay she was like literally like
my sister and I have talked about this
and because when you get older you look
back you can you can see what happened
as a kid you don't know what you don't
you don't see this [ __ ] you know what I
mean the [ __ ] was like jealous that I
was banging this other girl from [ __ ]
high school and she couldn't have me so
she would start fights with my father me
and my father
for the all the good that he was there
was the other side and was like Dr
Jekyll and Mr Hyde okay it was like he
could be so good so supportive in sports
and you know pay for like a leather
jacket and a good school clothes and
then on the other side it could be a
[ __ ] maniac and that [ __ ] was the
one that [ __ ] for some reason man she
had him so [ __ ] up in his head that
she could do no [ __ ] wrong and she
would start fights with us the first one
of the first fights was this is when we
were still living in the colony that was
the name of our subdivision where we
lived and uh
she they were bringing in groceries
right
and I go to open the door to help her
and she said something to me like get
your [ __ ] ass out there and pick up a
you know a thing and I think as a
teenager I said something I don't know
what I said like screw you or something
I don't know so anyway then I went back
in the kitchen I think I went back out
to help with the bags my father comes
running up on the porch and I'm more
embarrassed about people in the
neighborhood saying this he just starts
throwing punches at me hitting me over
and over again and I'm not gonna fight
back because this is my father I don't
want to hit my father I love my father
and he was like oh I [ __ ] had okay so
I'm not gonna fight back so anyway that
would happen then another time he he did
it another time he had flown if it
started hitting me and this time it was
weird because he had done it in the past
but then this time he acted like it was
the first he's like I'm so sorry I'll
never hit you again but that was
[ __ ] that didn't last long a couple
months ago he's doing it again okay and
then then the one time it was really bad
I had me around a dentist appointment in
the morning and I got up I got up and I
was I was leaving the door my stepmother
was leaving at the same time and she
[ __ ] mumbled [ __ ] something I don't
know what it was and I said something
like you know if I didn't want to go to
the dentist just a freaking big deal so
I of course she turns around runs
upstairs God knows what she told my
father he runs down again freaking out
throwing punches hitting me this time he
hit me he hurt me pretty bad because
when he finished I'm surprised I didn't
break my nose I was covered in blood
because he gave me a blood I mean I was
literally I was covered in [ __ ] blood
okay and and I was like I was just
devastated here now my father's abusing
my stepmother [ __ ] rapes me my
[ __ ] my head's a [ __ ] wreck I'm
I'm making I don't know how the [ __ ]
got through it I don't know how I
[ __ ] got through it anyway if I don't
remember remember to ask me about
suicide okay after I'm done with this
because there's something I gotta talk
about that anyway so I'm covered in
[ __ ] blood and I should have just
went to find I couldn't go to school
like that because I didn't want my dad
to get in trouble but I wish that I did
now I wish I did they would have saw
that and then found out what was
happening the whole sexual abuse and
everything but anyway at that point I
said to myself I looked down at myself
and I was like that's it no more he's
not [ __ ] hitting me again next time
I'm fighting back and it happened again
we were in this thing in living room
watching I don't know what happened she
started something or something pissed
him off he starts comes at me no no no
not this time [ __ ] I [ __ ]
slid in did a double egg takedown picked
him up over my [ __ ] shoulders like I
was a [ __ ] [ __ ] badass wrestler
man I can [ __ ] him up pick them up
over my shoulders and I was like I could
have slammed him and just [ __ ] beat
the [ __ ] out of slap the guillotine on
him and [ __ ] I could have [ __ ] been
sipping out of a straw the rest of his
[ __ ] life and I [ __ ] picked them
up and I didn't slam I let them down
easy
and I looked at him and he said first
thing he said to me is pack your bags
and I go you know I Let You Down Easy
you're not hitting me ever again I
didn't have to do that you're not
hitting me ever again never touched me
again never touched me again after that
and if he had came at me again
the next time I wasn't gonna let him
down easy I was gonna slam his ass I was
gonna [ __ ] him up I was gonna punch his
I would have [ __ ] snap this [ __ ]
neck I would I was gonna [ __ ] him up
because enough is enough your whole
huh you were how old yeah how old were
you oh how old was I think I was like 16
then
yeah probably 16. and you stayed in the
house yeah I was 16. uh after that
yeah well I was I was living with my
father yeah but it was awkward right
well yeah it was awkward it's all [ __ ]
up of course like I'm living in a
[ __ ] hell house and then make my
words my sister gets pregnant and 16
disappears out of the blue she's gone
moves with some [ __ ] scumbag to Texas
so it's just me my crazy stepmother my
crazy father living in this house and
then my father
we lived in this beautiful private
neighborhood and big pops with pillars
he bought some [ __ ] house he's gonna
remodel he never finished [ __ ] so I was
embarrassed about living there I didn't
want people to know I lived there it was
[ __ ] horrible it's like my whole life
everything was gone from a little kid to
having loving parents brothers and
sisters of [ __ ] the beach at the
bottom of the hill Woods to play in tree
houses I would build and [ __ ]
catching frogs and you know
sled right every [ __ ] possible
positive thing a child could have in
their life is growing up
was gone if this disappeared but because
I did have that good child and I think
that's the only reason I'm [ __ ]
saying today okay because when the [ __ ]
fell apart it was when I was like
hitting puberty okay anyway
okay I was with my now here's another
thing with my stepmother to be
completely honest I don't feel like I
was molested because at the time when
she actually
like it started when I was 14 and I
ended up sucking my dick like shortly
after my 15th birthday and the thing is
at that time of my life I was ready to
become sexually active I mean you know
teenage boys get laid at 15 16 all the
time that's not like a big deal so I
don't look at it like I was sexually
molest I definitely look at the
statutory rape definitely and that's a
whole nother thing too because you
remember back then it was [ __ ] up
something I think my girlfriend and I
were looking at some book it was telling
like the statutory rape laws back then
it was like if you were like you could
like bang a girl it was like 13 and in
in New Mexico and if she was okay with
it it was like legal like what the [ __ ]
man that generation was just [ __ ] up
those people anyway uh then I had a
problem where what was I going to say oh
and I have to ask myself if I'm gonna be
completely honest with myself
if this if I hadn't had OCD you know
that's something that's [ __ ] up this
woman does this to a guy that she knew
was [ __ ] up she knew I was [ __ ]
mentally [ __ ] up and she still does
this [ __ ] too what does that say about
that person so anyway
I have to ask I have to ask myself now
if I hadn't had OCD and if she wasn't my
stepmother okay there was just some
older woman
does that mean it might have been a good
experience it might have been fun I
might have been banging the [ __ ] out
right man I'm banging this older chick
you know might you know what I mean it
might have been a completely different
scenario if I'm completely honest I mean
I don't know you know but because of
this [ __ ] that went with it you know who
knows so it's it's so it's just a weird
[ __ ] thing you know all right now oh
I know where I was going to go with okay
now I'm doing all the associated you
must say to yourself Jesus Christ how do
you get through the [ __ ] day when you
got to do this [ __ ] all the time another
thing I would have to do is I would have
to like like if I saw something on the
floor if like pick like this little
thing right here I'd have to pick this
up and I have to pick up that there I
would spend hours time picking up every
little [ __ ] thing on the floor I
would have to every you could do that
you'd be stuck on the floor and then
once in the OCD attacks would come in so
they had the bad thought we'd picked up
doesn't have nothing good thought when
you pick up again anyway but you got it
got to the point where so bad where I
was like I want to just [ __ ] kill
myself I just want to kill myself but
guess what you can't even [ __ ] kill
yourself because you can't kill yourself
until you've caught up on the [ __ ]
rituals you gotta say that positive
thing enough times before you're even
allowed to kill yourself you couldn't
even [ __ ] kill yourself you're [ __ ]
man you're just stuck in this [ __ ]
hell there's no way around it and I
always feel like I was like like when I
say stuck I felt like there's this thing
covering over and I was like trapped I
always had this feeling of being trapped
but you were seriously suicidal at one
point no no no I wasn't because I wanted
to kill myself but I couldn't kill
myself because you had to catch up on
the rituals first so no you're not
suicidal because you don't have that
option I wish I had that option you
didn't even have that [ __ ] option it
was that [ __ ] up man you didn't even
have a way out man you're just [ __ ]
anyway uh okay
I had a few other OC oh I had this one
OCD oh this guy with a real popular kid
at school got killed in a car accident
uh you know that really affected me with
those he did I had there was a thing I
developed with OCD where like
say I was in a room and I was having an
attack I just and I was like stuck in a
in a room or somewhere and I had to keep
saying something over and over again
before I could leave I developed this
thing where if I had I couldn't possibly
stay in the room I had to go my friends
were waiting or something I could put it
on hold I'd leave go out boom and then
later that night I have to come back and
get back
I'd have to get back to it I put on hold
and after he died of course I had no CD
attack and there was I can't remember
what it was but I remember that thing
lasted a couple of months where I kept
having to go back to my room and say it
was original over and over and then come
out and get back to it later and finally
I got it under control and here's weird
too because anything could trigger you'd
have to say something again you see the
color pink that would mean like you're
gay so that's wimpy you have to see
blued offset that and any number of
things could trigger an OCD attack and
after I got that attack was really bad
that when I kept having coming back to
but but I learned to do that because
if you kept trying to get ahead of an
attack it would just increase and then
once you start getting upset then you
were really like [ __ ] because then you
then you you were really in trouble
because you couldn't be so I learned
that when I started couldn't getting
upset walk away from it I'll get back to
it later I'll come back to it later but
anyway I was did that with this OCD
attack was something you know that was
caused by his death and then the one day
that I oh yeah this is important after I
would say I would say I'm gonna save his
life I'm Gonna Save lifetime his life
save his life right after I finally got
it right the time was right the thought
was right I would have to make like a
sound like like a sound like that so
that so that I made that sound right
after I said it the last time so that
means I'm done I'm good because I made a
sound after that I don't have to go back
to that ritual anything that I see or do
for me or not I'm okay because the last
thing I did was make that sound you see
what I'm coming back with this okay so
anyway
I finally got that one under control and
I went over to visit a friend of mine
and he was doing a report in school on
abortion and his mother was a nurse and
she got an actual like fetuses and a
thing and I saw those and you would
think now that would [ __ ] me up with OCD
you know seeing those I just go back and
start saying but it didn't because I
made that sound first and I could move
on which it seems to me it makes no
sense the whole [ __ ] thing is like
ridiculous oh and then I had a fear that
uh you know something went in my head
that my girlfriend will end up getting
pregnant or something which did happen
anyway later in high school but anyway
that's a whole nother thing uh I would
be having sex with my girlfriend and
every time I thrust it in her if I
hadn't I would have OCD attacks and I
would have to keep count of how each
time I'm doing it and and keep track of
what I'm thinking while I'm doing that
that's how bad OCD was it even was in my
sex life I would have OCD when I'm in my
dreams even I'd wake up in the morning I
do and I go to sleep I have dreams I
would be doing it I really should touch
up on that on that a little bit too all
right the girl that I was seeing in high
school now again
okay she was a nobody I don't mean to be
mean right but she was and I did not
want to be with this chick I did you
know I had nothing to do with her you
know and I couldn't even break up with
her because every time I did I'd have to
have the right thought the right thing
I'd have to see that I'm stuck with this
girl these beautiful women I could have
had and I can't be I'm stuck with her I
couldn't get out of the way and then to
make matters worse if I was able to
every time I said I was gonna I was
gonna break up with it she'd say she's
gonna kill herself one time she put on
this big thing she had pills out and
everything and I'm terrified one of my
fears people are gonna die now she's
she's got me terrified she's gonna kill
herself every time I break up with her
and even once I went to the guidance
counselor and I told him I can't I just
couldn't take it anymore and he said
just break up with it instead she said
I'm like she kills herself it would be
my fault he's like no well no no he
didn't say no it won't he said he said
she's not gonna kill herself you know
but if he would have just said to me
said to me it won't be your fault I
would have been but nobody actually said
that so I was stuck with this [ __ ] all
through high school like the [ __ ] was
a nightmare and the reason she did that
is because she knew without me she was a
nobody she wasn't getting into the
parties she wasn't with the In Crowd she
was a nobody without me she knew that
you know what I mean but anyway that's
that's a whole nother thing but anyway
that did have an effect on my life
because from from that day on for from
that experience on I swore I'd never get
into a relationship again ever because I
I no way you know I mean because I
missed out on all these women like and
I'm all I've since then I've always been
trying to play catch-up you know bang as
many beautiful women as I can that's a
whole nother that's a whole nother OCD
thing that comes later that I would have
to I would have to get into you about
it's this is a whole nother aspect like
I said my life is so it's [ __ ] crazy
you know and anyway like I know where it
was oh uh oh
end of my ninth grade year
somehow someway
I pulled together enough strength enough
to not do the [ __ ] I had I was
supposed to not do a ritual like a bad
thought went in my head and I said no
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say like
it's like you're gonna kill somebody I
refuse to say no I'm gonna save your
life I wouldn't do it I said I'm not
gonna do it I gotta beat this thing [ __ ]
enough of this because like I said don't
forget every single day I woke up I was
determined to not do this I was going to
beat this and by some [ __ ] miracle I
didn't do the rituals and I and and I
always had like this kind of like a I
don't know if you want to call it a
not a fog not a cloud like something was
always over I didn't feel myself I was
never myself and when I finally stopped
doing these rituals stop I finally beat
this thing my mind went right back to
the way it was before I was myself again
I felt good again I was back I beat it
I'm [ __ ] clear unfortunately
I don't know a month two months later I
don't know what it was I'm sitting in my
room
and the closet door I went I went and I
shut the closet door and I sat down
that I had the urge to have to reopen it
again and I said to myself don't do it
dude don't do it don't [ __ ] do it
like
but I did I got up opened the door and
shut it again
I was [ __ ] again it was back I hope to
shut again open shot again OCD was back
again it [ __ ] completely back for
serotonin yeah that's what they say
something like that the serotonin
doesn't move like you're certain like
it's easy to say just stop doing that
but it doesn't work I found that I found
that in life I found that out in life
through years of OCD it doesn't work
anyway do you think it's genetic
yeah there's genetics too my they say my
grandfather had her my great grandfather
or something had it
no no it's not nothing like that no like
the psychiatrist and they first when I
first told about the sexual abuse uh
first I told my doctor and I think she
she thought maybe that's what caused it
but no my stepmother
yeah yeah but by yeah what I mean my
psychiatrist later like recently with
the OCD thing yeah yeah it was before
that though but but they thought maybe
it was that's what caused the OCD but no
I was I had OCD far before before that
happened no no OCD was just like I was
five years old the first OCD attack I
had but I just I didn't know what it was
and disappeared never came back all
right so anyway uh
some miracle I graduated from high
school another thing was always a
problem was [ __ ] religion
I mean
that was a nightmare I was brought up in
this you know Catholic Italian Catholic
thing you know uh you know uh
baptism catechism you know [ __ ] all
that horseshit uh
first communion and uh and then it was
weird because we my dad was my dad not
my mom so much and then one day we just
didn't go to church it was weird and my
weird little kids were like where the
house we were just like
you know we're kind of like man we're
looking at the clock man it's [ __ ]
like it's 8 30. he's not down here yet
you know like and we had to leave be at
church by nine like I'm like
and he didn't come down we didn't go to
church that day and we were just like I
want this don't say anything just just
let it and then we never went again it
just ended catechism and everything
ended but anyway I still had that
religious back that [ __ ] brainwashing
in my head so that was that was always a
problem with OCD too and a lot of people
I've read the OCD can stem from that too
from religion and uh so at night if I
had to say my prayers like our father
when I said amen it was a nightmare I'd
have to say it over and over I don't
have the exact right thought when I said
it but anyway at graduation like coming
up to graduation there's all these
different Banquets and things and they
always had a [ __ ] prayer like at the
end of the bag and that would [ __ ] me
up and so I had to keep count of how
many times I'd said amen and I was
sitting there ready to get the diploma
you know with a fake diploma they give
it to you get the real one later but and
I was like I was like just [ __ ] like
just get through this amen when they
said and somehow I got through it you
know and I graduated by some [ __ ]
miracle but here I am graduated I'm
completely [ __ ] have no education I
always kind of consider I only have an
eighth grade education because that was
eighth grade was the last time I [ __ ]
learned anything but that's not really
true because I've learned stuff on my
own since then
but uh so here I'm graduate where am I
gonna go what am I going to [ __ ] do
not one [ __ ] person made any effort
to help me or give me any guidance
nobody not a trade school not a cause
and I want to go to college I
desperately want like okay I was hoping
to get a wrestling scholarship but OCD
[ __ ] me up so bad in wrestling and I
was one of the best wrestlers in the
state now when I say that I wasn't one
of the best wrestlers in the state I had
the potential to be but OCD would [ __ ]
that up or I couldn't for example I
wrestled this one guy he took third this
is my junior year he was a senior I
wrestling he beat been me before I was
young he was really good I went Toe to
Toe with him he beat me by two points I
had him on the stall in the last round
and he was a third in the state my
junior year okay I had years later a
friend of mine who wrestled for a big
big college okay started
this was after this was years later uh
this was like after I got out of the
Navy I was like 22. and he was I think
that's kind of a jerk uh but anyway I
think he wanted to thought he was just
gonna kick my ass in wrestling you know
because I hadn't wrestled since high
school man I wrestled that he outweighed
Me by 20 30 pounds I went toe-to-toe
with this dude hadn't wrestled since
[ __ ] high school I went toe-to-toe
with him man he just was like it was
really bugging then he wanted to weigh
in and he saw that I weighed lastly you
wouldn't he was like really like
bothered the [ __ ] out of him you know
but see that's what I mean I had that
kind of potential but you know and
that's bad enough that it [ __ ] you up
in sports but the worst is it has [ __ ]
me up my education anyway so like I said
I mean you enjoy being a clown
excuse me yeah actually I do I mean a
lot of times I look at it like you know
I missed out on so much in life
that I you know could have been and done
because it's just [ __ ] up in the head
but uh
I make kids laugh there's no wrong in
that you know what I mean it's just you
know that's what I do I make kids laugh
I you know my critics can say what they
want you know but I can silence them we
need to say look I'm making children
laugh you know what I could I do parties
now where I was at somebody's party when
they were like six and I'm doing their
kids party you know and you know people
all the time come up to you that are
like older like in their 20s man you
were at my birthday party it was the
best one I ever had when I was six and
you know so it's there's no wrong in it
are you a clown instead of a doctor
lawyer politician whatever yeah well
that yeah because because of your OCD
yeah of course I never would have been
doing this of course
you kidding me I would I would I would
have graduated if I would have got out
of high school I would have went to
probably Penn State or Pitt
probably would have wrestled for those
schools
I was too small to play big football
though but I would have wrestled for
sure I would get a wrestling scholarship
for sure I would have went to college I
probably would have made your law
probably got into politics I was like
big time into politics and I was like
hey that's big time into debating all
that went away when I [ __ ] went with
OCD but now that I've done these meds
and I still love the debate man I go
toe-to-toe with anybody into debate on
any topic you discovered meds huh you
started taking meds win it was like
about seven years ago I went to that you
know what maybe no no actually that's
not true when I moved out to California
I had a couple bad attacks and I said
enough of this [ __ ] I said I never
wanted to take meds because I hate drugs
I don't drink I don't smoke I don't do
any drugs I'm like I can't drink smoke
or don't need drugs my brain you I
cannot do that okay you know and my bro
I'll be [ __ ] uh
but uh I I went to some I never bothered
to get my VA benefits when I should have
but I went to some psychiatrist in
Orange County and he put me on Luvox I
think that's what it was called and it
worked but not like the stuff I'm on now
and then he just then yeah I started
self-medicate I just drive to Tijuana
and get the meds you know what do you
take now
um Citra something saline I don't have
to look up a [ __ ] long name who's
helping you because of the nest yeah it
works really good
um but I was doing that
self-medicate doesn't work it's and then
I would get on and off and then you you
think with Med you get on meds and then
you're you're doing really well so you
think you don't need them anymore so
then you get off them then you're [ __ ]
you know what I mean that happens also
now I know you know dude just stuck and
I hate taking meds you know but yeah
what are you gonna do man your brain
doesn't work right you know what are the
downsides of the meds well for one thing
it's almost impossible to have an orgasm
that's one downside uh that's probably
the only one really it used to get like
joint pains and things but I think oh
that's pretty much gone now I don't
really get that anymore uh that's
probably the only really bad one you
sleep [ __ ] great with them you know I
mean you knocked out you know
and I'll and I'll skip my meds every now
and then like if I want to like watch
some porn and masturbate you know not
have to fight forever to get enough I'll
skip one I can skip a med like for you
know maybe a day a couple of days two
three days and three at the most I won't
chance it after that
um my psychiatrist doesn't want to hear
that you know I don't tell them that
that I skip them OCD affected your
romantic relationships oh of course me
so because you're taking the meds you
don't well no not like that uh a little
bit but not really
okay yeah I'm glad you brought that up
OCD enrolled that's good because that's
where we can we can start with that next
that's another one no we're I'm shooting
oh okay oh yeah well I'm gonna start
with that anyway uh I got out of high
school
and eventually I think I did get out of
that relationship with that [ __ ] girl
I mean the time was right the client was
able to fuss a miracle and I'm seeing
this other girl right
okay
I developed this thing where OCD would
come in my head it would say I'm about
to have sex with a girl my OCD would say
you're not gonna be able to get it up
now I can't get my dick hard
OCD is stopping me from having a [ __ ]
here I was stuck with this [ __ ] girl
all through high school now I'm able to
bang all these beautiful women and now
CD won't even let me do that and I
couldn't get my [ __ ] dick hard it
would OCD would say your dick's not
gonna get hard and guess what it ain't
getting hard it would not it wouldn't do
it
I went through a whole thing with that
and that lasted that comes and goes
still you know it's weird today like now
if I take the medication okay oh my dick
will get hard but now you can't come you
know what I mean so it's like if you
don't take your meds OCD will say your
dick's not gonna get hard and won't get
hard but so you take the meds and Well
for now you can't but now you can't
orgasm it's like what the [ __ ] man not
not to say that I haven't had some
really great sexual experiences in my
life that I can tell you about all that
later because I've traveled all over the
world and let me tell you something I
and you would think that that would be
enough that I could you know move on you
know and like make a commitment to
somebody but I can't but that's a whole
different thing I don't think that's an
OCD thing I just don't I just don't get
the whole marriage thing man you know I
well okay this doesn't really have
anything to OCD but I've been kind of
since we're on that topic
uh there is the thing with like where I
I was like in those relationships in
high school trap that I wanted a variety
of women over you know because I wanted
to cat I was always trying to play
ketchup I think of all the different
women I missed out on and even after I
got out I think there was a lot of
beautiful women I should have been
banging with I was I got caught up with
women that I really didn't want to be
with but I stayed with them they were
nice girls though but anyway uh because
I just forgot what I was gonna do oh I
know what I was gonna say uh no I could
never get married anyway there's nothing
to do with OCD I could not I don't get
marriage okay we seek Variety in every
aspect of Our Lives be it in music and
literature and films and foods and
travel and art we're always looking for
something new something different
something more exciting why would you
not look for a variety in your sex life
too see I don't get that how can you be
one person your entire life that's it I
mean there's a plethora of variety out
there I mean look at all the different
continents just that Asian South America
you know North America you know Indian
uh you know Africa this is Europe and
and then and with each of one of those
if you take like Asia you've got
Vietnamese women and the Cambodian women
in Chinese and Japanese and then on that
you've got women with mohawks short hair
nowhere you know cheerleader type
sophisticated types punkers you know
rockers there's such a variety of women
there how can you possibly and for women
too a variety of men how can you
possibly be the one person for the rest
of your life till the day you die it'd
be like eating the same thing every
[ __ ] day it'd be like eating pizza
every day of your life every day not
just eating pizza but eating the same
exact slice of pizza every day for the
rest of your life I don't get that maybe
I'm missing something because a lot of
people get married and a lot of people
like it and a lot of people find
fulfillment and that's so you know maybe
I'm missing something I got nothing I
mean more power I got nothing against it
you know but for me I just can't imagine
that you know anyway that's a that's a
whole nother thing all right anyway get
out of high school and oh it's another
thing I had a job in high school I
worked at this truck stop I'm late for
work every [ __ ] day because I'm an
OCD right but I just managed it was so
[ __ ] cool she was mean and tough and
strong and she'd cuss you out and give
you hell she was like this big kind of
like truck driver kind of looking lady
but she was [ __ ] fair and I'd come in
like two hours late for work man every
[ __ ] weekend most of the times I was
at a party the night before at this
point and you know I can't I can't
totally say it was all OCD and I was
like banging my girlfriend all night
then you know the football you know the
football game you go to the big party
the keg party then you go bang your
girlfriend all night and then you crawl
out you're supposed to be at work at
eight I don't get there till 10. but she
never busted my balls about it because
when I got there I worked my ass off and
she knew that and I was really good I
was like a busboy right and then later I
became a cook but I was like she knew
that and she would cuss you out someone
she didn't choose to but she was fair
and honest you know what I mean her I
would say her and my football coach were
two people that really did uh support my
life it's kind of like they knew I was
[ __ ] up but they saw the potential
there even if they didn't say it they
knew it you know what I mean they knew
this guy there was just something wasn't
working right with this guy anyway while
I'm working at this truck stop okay
uh
it was mostly high school for a while
there when I worked it was all high
school kids there it was like me this
guy this other guy went to another
school there was the cook me and then
this girl that I went to high school she
was the servant it was like three of us
we're running the whole [ __ ] that's
it there was even a manager around three
[ __ ] high school kids were [ __ ] on
this restaurant and let me tell you
something things got pretty [ __ ]
crazy doing you know I'm your high
school kids you know what I mean I don't
know how the thing even worked with
having us there eventually they brought
I think that's what they brought her in
as the manager she used to work that she
said I think they brought her into kind
of rain in the creek you know they you
know these kids like wait a minute you
know we gotta you know have you know the
owner was a cool guy it was just a cool
place to work as a kid
but anyway at this place later there was
this there was this family that worked
and these people were poor you know this
was like the the mother was a server
there her daughter was a server I think
their son was like worked at the in the
at the gas station part of the truck
stop and this one girl like the other
girls that worked there are like these
really young like really like pretty
high school wealthier from wealthier
families you know these young real
beautiful girls you know from wealthy
families you know and this poor girl was
like you know poor and kind of
overweight and you know I just must have
been hard on her and anyway I come into
work one day and Pat the lady I'm
talking about the manager and you never
saw her cry she was crying man I never
saw her cry before she was sitting at
the table and crying tears were out
about I was like I was like what
happened what happened and uh that young
girl
her father okay took a knife and he
[ __ ] sliced her up like a [ __ ]
Christmas ham man she had [ __ ] scars
every stitches all over her [ __ ] body
like went after with a [ __ ] butcher
knife or something and just [ __ ] cut
her to Pieces man it's like this is the
[ __ ] generation those [ __ ] people
man they did this this poor [ __ ] girl
and this girl I can't believe how well
she was handling it you know what I mean
she was like so strong it [ __ ] makes
me emotional when I think about it this
woman was so strong this young girl man
a [ __ ] teenager and she was so strong
out she endured that and you know what
nothing even happened to that [ __ ]
guy and everything oh oh oh
how can I forget this okay here's the
okay my stepmother and that whole sexual
abuse my father the physical abuse
here's the punch line you're gonna love
this my father is the director of
children's services my stepmother is the
head of the adoption agency how you like
that is that a [ __ ] punch line for
you
Jesus [ __ ] Christ yeah I ain't
[ __ ] you imagine that and there was
some big scandal at Children's Services
my senior year I remember I don't know
because I was [ __ ] up with those CD I
couldn't follow I can't imagine what the
[ __ ] was going on at that place they're
probably [ __ ] raping teenagers left
and right at that goddamn [ __ ] place
yeah how you like that for a punch line
anyway this girl and my father was a
good social worker I mean we were kids I
remember we used to be like kids that
were like didn't that were homeless
because their parents would be they
would stay at our house until they found
a place now he did all that and this is
when I in and I came and I told this
girl I said look my dad's ahead of
director still in the service I'll get
to some help and I thought and my dad I
told him he's like no no I want to get
involved right now we have a and that's
when I knew that his heart wasn't in
social work anymore you know and then I
had to go back and tell her this and
it's just and anyway that guy her father
did that to her nothing ever even
happened to the [ __ ] he didn't even get
arrested nothing even happened to the
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] that's how they
used to treat teenagers back then they
and you wonder why these teenagers would
grow up you know like in like they're in
their 30s then you hear them they go and
they those guys that that kid that hid
in the garage and blew his [ __ ]
parents away yeah you wondered why they
[ __ ] did that well that's [ __ ] why
you know what I'm saying that's why they
[ __ ] did it you know I'd love to blow
my [ __ ] stepmother let me I would
love to blow her [ __ ] brains out and
they wonder why people grow up okay and
then they they [ __ ] are like you know
what he killed his [ __ ] father yeah
why'd he kill his [ __ ] what did his
[ __ ] father do to him his whole
[ __ ] life you know what I mean but
that's how they treated teenagers back
then today I think it's different you
know it's not you know I think they take
the teenager said because it's like my
generation if a teenager says something
you know great I can't just lie too
there's blood I know this [ __ ] of
course but you're gonna take you take it
more seriously back then nobody gave a
[ __ ] man it was like you know you do
whatever you especially if you're a
teenage boy you can do whatever you want
to that man don't [ __ ] matter you
know it's like you know I had a girl
once said to me oh you loved it that's
what's the [ __ ] ass attitude I'm like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] but you know
I shouldn't say that like that because a
lot of women I have and not many people
have told that about they were
compassionate about it you know so I
think I'm not going to say that oh mo
even most women react that way most
women are compassionate about but there
is a thing though without a doubt when
it's a boy a young guy there still is a
thing where you know boys will be boys
with whether it's a teenage girl it's
different and it shouldn't be but that
is it is like that but you know
it is it is what it is you know as I'm
talking I'm actually having some OCD
attacks like having to remember to say
so I can feel it like right here so I've
been doing I was all going through this
anyway get out of high school where's
your nose oh geez yes of course my nose
this this is the worst part of being a
clown putting on the [ __ ] clown nose
yeah you have to make sure you the hat
in the nose you have to make sure your
skin
is really
really dry but if that same girl that
did say that smart ass comment this is
the OCD attack I just had I have to have
to remember what I was going to say I'll
say it was going to bug me she did she
did also say to me you know you know
something about don't let her get away
with you have to tell your story some
something of that sort you know you
wanted to get away with you know she'll
get away with it you gotta let people
know so she did even though she said
that comment so it's not really fair for
me to you know because it's not fair I
don't want to come up that I'm like you
know women here at God something like
that happened to a guy and I'm like you
know women are like oh too bad he's a t
that's not true majority of women do
they they feel bad for the guys too
you know but anyway I graduated from
high school I go through I'm working at
this place I got nowhere to go
oh then I met this other girl
okay remember I told you the thing where
OCD wouldn't let me dick hard I meet
this other girl she's like her car she
smashed her car into something I think
she drove it on price I seen this girl
she was not attractive at all she was
like a druggie girl you know and uh oh
this is something I should mention uh I
never did drugs or anything now here's
another thing okay
now smoking marijuana is no big deal to
me at all I'm glad voted for legal
matter of fact I have no problem with
people doing drugs as a matter of fact I
think all drugs should be legal I do
have a problem with people that do drugs
they can't afford to do drugs so they
break into my property and rip out all
the copper so they can buy their drugs
you know it'd be like me he wanted to
eat at a five-star restaurant every
night but I can't afford it so I Rob and
steal to do it I do have a problem with
that but if you want to do drugs do all
the drugs you want if you can afford
them I could care less anyway I I
started smoking marijuana which I never
did before
and this was a kind of a
dangerous thing with OCD because
sometimes I'd get high and you could get
so caught up in an OCD attack while you
were high you'd be like deep deep that
you couldn't come out of it you know and
then and then I pull myself it was a
very very short-lived thing I never
liked it I never there was nothing I was
never interested in but now
but now I could have say I had an OCD
attack where I smoked marijuana
and I had no CD attack the first time I
did it so I had to smoke it again okay
to offset the thought I had the first
time I spent you could you could OCD
could literally force you to have to
smoke marijuana every day now people
would look at that and say oh he's
addicted to marijuana no he ain't
addicted to marijuana he's got [ __ ]
OCD I'm gonna let him stop doing it okay
now now OCD I don't I would say had I
wouldn't I guess this would be a
positive effect okay for the last like
40 years every [ __ ] day I eat two
apples two oranges a banana cucumber
carrot tomato every day once a week I
buy them I wash them all off really good
dry them with a paper even watch the
Skins you know and everything even the
ones with the skins on and put them in a
plastic bag sealed up with a twisty nice
and you know safe and contamination free
and every day one of those and two cans
of tuna every [ __ ] day okay now say I
was an alcohol say it went the other way
I told myself psychiatrist one of my
psychiatrists they went the other way
and I was drinking and I had an attack
where I had to drink beer every day okay
because of OCD all right and I wouldn't
even say that's an OCD thing now but I
guess it probably is a kind of okay
people would say oh he's an alcoholic no
he ain't an alcoholic he's got [ __ ]
OCD that's why he has to keep drinking
see what I mean people wouldn't see that
anyway I get I have nowhere to go what
I'm gonna do with my [ __ ] life I'm
completely [ __ ] so what do I do I join
the Navy I had nowhere else to go what
else was I going to do you know let me
tell you something I got the boot camp I
loved it for one thing I didn't like
about it was too damn easy I got out of
boot camp I was in the worst shape of my
life because it was so easy I excelled
okay the OCD wasn't really around much
uh
I won the push-up contest like I think
79 push-ups or something I was athletic
petty officer and it was [ __ ] great
in the Navy because now
everything had to be an exact way there
was no questioning it I was putting my
shoes away was always a nightmare do
they go this way do they have where do
the laces go it was always a problem
they go this way it's been hours doing
that not in the Navy the shoes go
exactly like this the laces go in the
shoe the bed gets folded exactly like
this perfectly everything had to be
straight perfect perfect oh my God I
felt [ __ ] relieved it was like yes
finally these questions don't have to be
answered I don't have to worry about am
I doing the bed right am I [ __ ]
putting my clothes on right no this
shirt had to be exact this had to be
exact it was [ __ ] great it was like
and I [ __ ] excelled man of course you
know because it was just like you know
it was perfect there was no question
what happens after that I become a male
stripper because I'm good looking and
I'd [ __ ] make a ton of [ __ ] money
I'd become like a [ __ ] famous
stripper in [ __ ] Buffalo I become
rich this [ __ ] hell I'm buying up
[ __ ] properties [ __ ] everywhere
I I cheat I [ __ ] for I changed my
[ __ ] are we on right now yeah oh God
I'm still staying in any way I changed
my name okay I I forged a birth
certificate right got a new whole new
social security number whole new
driver's license everything hold an
identity that I I won't say the name I
have I still have it today I could use
it today if I want I paid taxes on it I
serve jury duty it's completely [ __ ]
different thing and at that time and I
was I was in Tampa see if it's better if
I can start from the beginning and show
you how it led up to all this stuff but
that's what ended up happening okay all
right and then uh I don't know if you
want to get into all the details of all
that but uh I had it I got OCD under
control okay when I was in Tampa I hit
rock Bob and again I stopped it and this
time I [ __ ] stopped it for good it
was I didn't do it I mean and I'm
watching Phil Donahue and he's got a
show on OCD and that's where I learned
what the [ __ ] I had
such a big weight off my shoulder like
that's what's [ __ ] wrong that's my
problem my girlfriend gives me the book
The Boy Who couldn't stop washing so I
read that and everything makes sense and
now I say to myself wait a minute I
didn't do anything wrong when I went aw
I was [ __ ] crazy I [ __ ] I realized
you know and one of the first things I
did was I got a lawyer because I was
going to get out of the Navy but the
lawyer was [ __ ] he's like he wasn't
going to help me at all so I didn't so
that's when I changed my name and did
all that and I'm making a ton of [ __ ]
money man I made so much fun I was so I
was like sounds gorgeous I was a good
looking guy I started my I started my
own yes how long did you work as a
stripper like 10 about eight years eight
years I made a fortune I had my own
company guys at work I started in Erie
Pennsylvania and I went than I did in
Tampa then in Buffalo Buffalo's where I
made most of my and I had guys that
worked for my my own group I bought up I
was buying a ton I was about bidding
guys on properties that were twice and
this is when I had OCD under control
because now it's under control I'm
kicking ass man I'm back baby I'm
[ __ ] making money I'm [ __ ] got my
own business you're looking at a guy I
was [ __ ] in the Navy completely if I
couldn't do anything now he's 22 years
old okay and I'm making I'm making a
fortune as a stripper then like by the
time I'm 24 I got 24 I had OCD under
control now I'm [ __ ] like a leading
[ __ ] I'm eating the best [ __ ]
restaurants I [ __ ] got a beautiful
girlfriend I got [ __ ] it I'm [ __ ]
kicking ass man I'm like [ __ ] making
more money than my father who's a
professor now I got [ __ ]
um it's like crazy man because OCD is
under control now but it wasn't under
control I started having other attacks
that I couldn't control thoughts would
not I wouldn't do the thing where I had
to say something over and over again but
now I had thoughts would not leave my
head and they've bombarded me and
bombarded me okay then there's a lot I
could get into on this there's a whole
lot of other [ __ ] I could tell would
blow you away but we want to wrap this
up so we're gonna I'm gonna just put
this in speed zone okay long story short
this girl I was gonna marry she was
black right as soon as my [ __ ] uh uh
okay and I was raised never to be a
racist my stepfather a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] as soon as I announced when I'm
getting married to a black girl guess
what all of a sudden I get [ __ ]
turned in it turns me into the [ __ ]
but actually it wasn't quite like that
if I get a call from my step this is
right after I announced engagement to my
girlfriend who's African-American she's
actually half black she's half polish
that black [ __ ] gorgeous [ __ ] girl
okay but that's a whole nother thing
like I said I'm not going to get into
all that I keep going there's so much
there's so many things that would blow
you away but we want to wrap this up
so anyway
I get a call and he says yeah the police
were here looking for you I'm like what
and I missed me and he made I
immediately thought it was the Navy and
he didn't say he made it sound like it
was and and then anyway it's like
there's no doubt in my I mean the odds
of that happening exactly at that time
we're like a million to one anyway so I
mean because I was a dick man he just he
[ __ ] me over completely I never liked
that piece of [ __ ] anyway and I wish I
would have kicked his ass when I was in
high school anyway uh
so what do I do
I didn't [ __ ] run and I went right
back to the Navy I went back man I went
back I went straight to Bethesda went
straight to the cycle and I told him
what the [ __ ] happened and let me tell
you something the Navy could not have
been more understanding these people
were [ __ ] from the minute I got there
they were [ __ ] behind they had my
back and you know why because in the
military they deal with mental illness
all the [ __ ] time you got guys going
off the wars they see people getting
their heads cut off they get [ __ ] up
in the head so when you come back and
they hear this [ __ ] that's going on in
your head what happened they get it
they're like Jesus Christ they're like
no we get it man you're [ __ ] up
they get it every single person through
the step help me out matter of fact I
when I went back I went to Bethesda and
they sent me to Norfolk was that would
have been my last command I'm there
right away they start giving they give
me an ID they start giving me a paycheck
they start paying me they give me a Meal
Pass I'm getting these amazing meals
I'm on a [ __ ] plane that [ __ ]
night I'm back in Buffalo I'm and then
we go over to Canada and we're not
having dinner with my girlfriend in
Canada they're not [ __ ] back in the
military it was [ __ ] crazy I couldn't
believe it and when I tried to turn
myself in it was almost impossible
everywhere I went these dudes are like
you sure you want to do this I'll show
you what to do I'm like look yeah I
really want to do this like are you sure
man are you sure it's like it was crazy
I couldn't believe it anyway
every step of the way through the
military everybody I talked to through
the chain of command and told my story
we're a hundred percent backed me up
while we understand oh my God this is so
horrible never did anybody for any way
you were no it wasn't like that at all
they got it somebody it was [ __ ] nice
because finally somebody acknowledged
this so this was like like proof you
know why my grades were so bad why
things had gone so wrong in my [ __ ]
life they [ __ ] got it okay
I got an honorable discharge all charges
dropped honorable discharge I got VA
benefits today I mean I I feel like you
know I feel like I could cry just
thinking about it now because the
see this is why I get emotional man
because I'm very [ __ ] patriotic I
love my country and I wanted to serve my
country honorably that [ __ ] couldn't
and the military [ __ ] came through
for me and it was like in the [ __ ]
goddamn mostly and the one regret that I
really do have is that when I went back
I wish I would have instead of just
getting a dis trying to get a discharge
I wish I would have said you know what I
only had about a year and so many months
left to start I wish I would have said
no I'd rather just serve out the rest of
my time if I can although I know that's
kind of ridiculous because
I was [ __ ] crazy and you can't have
somebody with OCD I don't think you can
get in if you have OCD now I don't think
you can I mean you can't I don't think
that would have even been a possibility
that is a regret that I have you
struggled through most of your life not
knowing what you had yeah yeah well I
know like I said in Tampa I figured out
what it was but you know it was just at
the military they got it you know what I
mean and it was like and my brother Matt
once said to me he's like he's like yeah
it's like you're being Vindicated like
you know now you got this conversation
it shows that you know you're not this
is [ __ ] up that's like proof you know
what I mean it's I hate this [ __ ] when I
start like [ __ ] getting emotional and
[ __ ] like this oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
man
but but that's the one that's the one
thing out of OCD that I regret the
[ __ ] most I mean even the education
everything is bad but I'm so patriotic I
always love my I just want to serve my
country honorably in a [ __ ] OCD took
that from me you know and that that that
does bother me
you know but anyway okay I wish I could
say
oh get this
after I got my discharge I got out
okay now I had an OCD attack that forced
me out of the Navy now after I got out I
was having another OC attack that would
have forced me back in completely
opposite so if but I knew what OCD was
and I was able to control it so
otherwise it could have been like I
could have ended up stay because of OCD
I could end up staying in for like 20
years like oh he liked it but no it
wasn't even before it did the opposite
the OCD that's the opposite force was
forcing me to go back in
so OCD is just a it's a chemical
imbalance in your brain I guess I don't
know I don't I guess that's what it is
but you got it under control now
somewhat not really because I'm having
an OCD attack right now where I'm
talking to you is that right yeah
because I'm having a so T Tech where I
wanted to say that thing again where I
said I could be in there for like 20
years you know and they'd think that you
know I uh I loved it but it was OCD keep
me I had that was an ocds I had to say
that but I don't know why do I have to
[ __ ] say it's not even relevant
really but anyway you know that's kind
of well that is I would be though so you
still struggle with it but I still have
OCD it doesn't go away and I would like
to say that after that it was all okay
but no it wasn't because after that I I
slipped into other ocds I ended up
losing a ton of [ __ ] money you know
and then I uh one day I uh I owned a big
candy store in Toronto and if I didn't
make any money the kids stole more than
they bought and then I added in Niagara
Falls and I moved to the building I
owned in Buffalo and one day a lady came
in and she was looking for a clown and
I'd done a few of those things when I
owned it like when I was a male stripper
let me specify that it's not like a
stripper you're like neutered there's no
nudity or anything like that and you
don't know if you remember that when
that was the big thing male strippers
knew they were like did she go to like a
50th birthdays and bat there's no nudity
or anything back then was it was like
very you know it was like it was the
first time you ever had anything like
that I also did like singing telegrams
I'd done clown stuff before then but I
was a horrible clown that I wasn't a
professional clown I just did if I'd
have anybody else to send out so I had I
you know had experience as a performer
uh but anyway lady came looking for
classic you know I bet I could do that
you know yeah you should do it I see
with these kids you're really good with
these kids and so I just put together an
old costume I had and I basically just
went and acted like an idiot and the
kids loved me I put an ad in the Yellow
Pages next thing I know I was making way
more money I did in that candy store
which I made nothing and then I was just
like you know I'm gonna move to
California and then I wanted to be I was
thinking I want to be an actor which was
also another ridiculous because I was
very very good as a performer but that's
an impossible thing too how am I gonna
[ __ ] be an actor I can't even read a
script like if you know what I'm saying
I can memorize you give me a script give
me an hour or two I'll memorize the
entire [ __ ] thing and then I'll
[ __ ] blow you away but I can't like
pick it up and read it like you know
like [ __ ] there's no way I could do so I
came here the reason I was going to be
an actor I was going to be a clown on
the side on the weekends while I went to
auditions and that and but then when I
realized you ain't gonna [ __ ] be able
to do this you can't [ __ ] read so
anyway so anyway I just became a
professional clown and I got really
[ __ ] good at it and uh
and I still had many OCD attacks along
the journey I was like in here I could
like I said we'd be here forever man I
can tell you some other [ __ ] that'll
blow you the [ __ ] away some [ __ ] that
happened to me I uh
but anyway uh at one point I lost
[ __ ] everything again but then I
[ __ ] busted my ass I've made it all
back again now I have a history of that
in my life I've made money and I lost
made it didn't lose I made it but I
can't do that anymore because I'm
getting too old to [ __ ] do that
but the key thing was I started seeing a
psychiatrist
she got me on the proper medication and
since that time it was like seven years
ago I am now completely I'm not not
completely totally it but I'm
totally sane as I've ever been I've got
it back I'm moving forward I'm opening
the largest clown Museum in the world
and you know I just go forward from here
you know I mean who knows what's gonna
happen I don't know man I mean I can
wake up one day and the meds don't work
and I'm [ __ ] I don't know I don't
think that's gonna happen your life is
better now than it's ever been finally
for the first time for the first time in
my life I can actually be myself which
isn't which is a good thing but in
sometimes senses it's not because a lot
of things that I can that I'll openly
say to people now OCD would keep me like
things I might say to my parents now
that I wouldn't have said before because
OCD would wouldn't let me say it now
I'll come out and say it so there's that
side of it too but I'm fine for the
first time my acts this is me this is
how I am man this is where I go I go
forward and uh things are good now this
is where that's where I go you know I
guess that's it it's a hell of a story
thank you all right Steve thank you very
much sorry I know I got long-winded man
okay there was something that I left out
that's a little important I just want to
add to this
okay this this is what happened with
that whole thing with my the sexual
abuse from my stepmother I made the
mistake of telling my mother about it I
remember the day I told her we were
talking my mother was always dogging out
my father constantly and my stepmother
of course why wouldn't she be she and I
was at the table talking with her once I
said I could tell you something Bonnie
did once it's really bad and right away
I knew to myself don't say don't tell
her don't tell her don't tell her and
she kept prodding and praying so that I
told her and then she was like crying
and upset but
anyway then then I said don't you dare
tell Dad don't you because I didn't want
my dad to know and then she called me
like a day later and said oh I'm gonna
tell my don't I begged her not to tell
me and she said she wasn't going to and
then she ended up telling and she had
what she ended up doing like I said my
father worked for children's services
she goes to Children's Services and
tells them and then so anyway uh I was
lifting weights and my father come and I
tried to avoid my father as much as I
could and then he said he had to talk to
me I remember a friend of mine was over
then he left my friend when it was
waiting for me I told and I was so naive
I thought I just told my father I can't
believe I thought my father would just
be like you know well it was a long time
ago you're like what was I thinking and
I said I told him what happened and my
stepmother I swear she would have killed
me I swear to God the way she looked at
myself she freaks out you relax
and he totally believed her didn't
believe the word I said and they
basically threw me out of the house and
today even to this day he won't speak to
me I mean we'd had a relationship before
that because it kind of I never brought
it nobody ever brought it up but I
recently mailed him a copy of my book
and after that night that was like three
years ago he wanted not speak to me at
all to this day thinks I lied and made
the whole thing up and I would like to
say that my mother would did this like
because she but she basically just did
this just another way to get even with
him because she never really didn't give
a [ __ ] either I don't think but he uh
that was it man he just uh he didn't
give a [ __ ] I'm you know another thing
he's laying this guilt trip on me that
oh you've jeopardized your jobs and now
I'm feeling guilty first of all because
I had sex with his wife then I'm also
feeling guilty because now I caused all
this trouble to his poor wife I'm
feeling guilty that that certain
Services found out about it I didn't
even say it in the first place my
[ __ ] mother did so I got double guilt
anyway I wanted to get that off my chest
[ __ ] it anyway I'm a clown everything's
good now take care